I've never seen a hotel and in in such
disarray there needs to be structure and
there isn't structure it's just like a
scramble it's a mess there was no order
in the kitchen nobody took
responsibility for any one thing no one
has been taught any standards in any
department really it's like I'm racing
from thing to thing nobody knows what
the other ones do it there's nobody here
that is in control willing to take
charge I did 40 [ __ ] dinners by myself
tonight I could help you in your asks I
can cook the rack of lamb excuse me
bragging about one plate is nothing to
brag about excuse me excuse me
I am the boss you can't call yourself
the boss if you don't [ __ ] pay them I
mean honestly do you think that's normal
Ari do you think that's the way to look
after your team every pay period there
is a problem with the checks every paper
there's a problem of the cheque and a
lot I don't know what the problem is I'm
but I know it's a Saint chippy and you
get to know about it first all you have
to go ask him for your salary I always
ask for that's absolutely wrong and the
reason is he's lying no no no he's not
lying I would rather have them wait then
write a check that's going to bounce
because I don't how about telling him
it's not gonna be ready rather than
having to ask like sons kivi cap in hand
please sir now get paid
anybody else have to wait how long
Barbara I had to wait five weeks that's
what I had to wait five weeks before I
got a paycheck five weeks
guys you come in and you work your ass
off the least these two guys can do is
pay your [ __ ] salary on time
I don't have a secretary Gordon I'm
sorry I'm trying to communicate with
brides I'm trying to send out things I
have to have peaceful time in order to
do my work are you always this pathetic
I am NOT pathetic well when are you
gonna stand up and start showing some
respect for your team and start growing
a pair to sort of understand the mess
you're in I understand the mess we're in
crime fighting for the team you dug the
[ __ ] hole yes and put a minute so
there [ __ ] they don't have to work here
oh my me you know the bottom line how
dare you know they don't have to work
here how dare you how [ __ ] dare you
they don't have to work here oh my god I
either get disrespectful disgusting man
they don't have to work here I don't
think you realize how [ __ ] lucky you
are because it wasn't four one two three
four five six of them you'd be driving
that RV miles away from here Robert
definitely needs a reality check
it's life or death right now and I don't
think he actually realizes what kind of
jeopardy this place is in there's not
all about you Robert Roberts world
rubbers bubble Roberts dream you're not
the lord of the manor and you're not the
Great Gatsby you aw you're Robert it's
only me in here excuse me excuse me
go on then you pompous [ __ ] excuse me
don't talk to me much what what's wrong
with it
I want to know what don't speak to me
like I'm telling you yeah yeah head out
your ass and start getting a little
[ __ ] real you still haven't got it
that this place is sinking start paying
a little bit more attention to the guys
on the ground understand how hard it is
out there forget your [ __ ] antique
road show
and start from the bottom running this
business you're right there's no
structure it's fragmented the team needs
a leader they need a structure
I need a mentor I need some support and
all they get is nitpicked what kind of
motivation is that all I've heard since
I've been here you're just blaming
people
well I'm blaming you for not taking
charge get [ __ ] real
[Music]